julia thank you for speaking with us we
really appreciate it i want to just get
a picture of what things look like in
kiev right now walk us through what life
is like right now in ukraine and in kiev
where you are
what are you seeing what are you hearing
how are you holding
up
well uh
we've been preparing for this uh
psychological and military devastating
threat in kiev for a couple of days
right now
but the intensity of shelling of kiev
hasn't been so intense as it is uh in
kharkiv for instance or in marijuana at
the moment but we do expect
the fear um aggressive uh campaign of
russians in the nearest days today they
um hitted
our television tower
and uh they also
warned that they are going to bomb the
administration office of security
service of ukraine uh which is actually
located near the sacred places of uh
orthodox christian uh
spiritual uh uh
spiritual grounds uh sofia kiev's
cathedral for instance and what is very
important and symbolic about this that
this cathedral which is belonging to
unesco heritage hasn't been destroyed
neither by
attack
mongol invasion in
in
2012
and uh nor in the
second world war by the fascist nazis so
it would be extremely incredible if
russians who consider kiev to be the
cradle of
uh christians uh spirituality just uh
are willing to bomb these sacred places
so we do expect that uh this desperation
and despair that russians troops and
russian political leadership are
experiencing at the moment will be
transferred into these brutal attacks on
civilians which are actually they are
doing already and also on these sacred
places of kiev
yulia osmo
thank you so much for joining us i know
that you are on the ground in kiev where
the tv tower was just hit and a 40-mile
russian convoy is lined up and ready to
go
does the fall of kiev potential fall of
keeve feel inevitable to you as you sit
there
no uh i don't expect the fall of kiev i
do expect fierce fighting
for kiev and actually we used to have
since the second world war uh the brands
like hero cities and hero towns all over
the soviet union which actually bravely
fighted against uh fascist nazis and
they received this label like kiev
a hero city
harke a hero city minsk hero city moscow
a hero city so right now we seems to
rebranding with the new meaning
these hero cities cave cities like
kharkiv like mario pal uh like kiev so
definitely we are prepared for a very
decisive very cruel fight with russians
uh for kiev and we don't expect the gift
to fall definitely what specific
diplomatic actions are multilateral
organizations like nato and the un
currently not taking that you would
encourage them to take
actually at this moment i don't see that
any negotiations offered to russians
will bear fruit
because
the two sides i mean the russians and
ukrainians
have extremely polar
demands which are unacceptable for
another side for instance yesterday
talks uh finished with no uh with
results uh uh
explicit results and it was quite
expectable to have nothing as an outcome
of these talks because russians still
demanded their uh ultimatum like to
recognize crimea being a russian land
to uh
for ukraine to give up its uh european
and euro-atlantic aspirations to join uh
eu and nato and uh
all other things like that and ukrainian
sides were quite uh
precisely their demands
first is immediate ceasefire and then
secondly withdrawal of russian troops
all over the ukrainian territory so
uh
it was quite
foreseeable that uh nothing came out of
this the only positive thing is that
the two sides agreed to have the second
round which is going to be tomorrow so
it means that at least
the room for negotiations uh are still
there so this facility hasn't closed but
what we expected my assessment is that
uh russians because they failed with
this blitzkrieg campaign in a couple of
days
and they felt short literature for
logistics like fuel food water for their
combat troops so they need some powers
to uh be uh themselves up and to get new
troops coming in with uh restored
logistics so they just winning this time
a more cruel attack it is a deceitful
tactic and strategy of russians but
ukrainian side is well aware of this and
they are prepared that uh
if russians are sitting at the
negotiation tables it means nothing it
means that
they are still prepared for something
more brutal and we do have this
experience of uh
um in famous minsk talks when uh which
happened
actually two serious battles and
russians just forced ukrainians to sign
these agreements which were contrary to
ukrainian statehood so it sounds like
what you're saying is that the
negotiations are mainly for optics for
it to look like russia is willing to
engage in diplomacy
of course what europe and the u.s are
counting on are sanctions and i know in
mid-february you said you doubted that
the u.s and european threats of severe
economic sanctions would deter russia
and that has pretty much been the case
at this point is there anything else
economically that the us and europe
could do to deter russia
yes uh i i have to say that what we
experience right now it's incredible
complete different picture of what's
going on both with sanctions and also
with
some positions of european union like
enabling uh the submission of
uh offensive weapons to to third party
which are in in the war right now and
also we are speaking we're talking
seriously right now about ukraine
joining eu on special procedure so uh in
terms of sanctions what we see and which
is very encouraging uh we were talking
last time uh about the possibility of
these sanctions being imposed on the
level of uh governments and
uh countries but right now we also see
that private companies corporations uh
business culture
all over the world are joining this uh
um and we have this spillover effect of
a huge condemnation of russians actions
and a lot of different actors state and
non-state actors are joining this
campaign so i think that sanctions
they've really done a quite dramatic
effect on russian economy because rubble
was depreciated yesterday up to 30
percent of its value and
a lot of financial institutions are on
the edge of bankruptcy in russia at the
moment and for instance in famous
company operator of north stream 2
hinted that they had to confess that
they on the urge of bankruptcy so i do
think i do see this spillover effect and
i
see that
the european countries and the united
states and all our partners in the
western world they're quite creative and
inventive with new mechanisms of
sanctions so on this side i'm quite
optimistic and to confess uh while
talking to a ukrainian mps politicians
who are involved in in this
fight right now they've already just
lost the count of all these different
mechanisms that are being introduced by
our partners well i want to talk about
the sanctions element here because a lot
of global power is of course putting
forth sanctions that are crippling
russia's economy but i've wondered if
that's going to change putin's behavior
especially given the way that he's
sanction-proofed his own economy do you
think putin cares not just about the
cost of war for his own country but
about the economic ramifications for
everyday folks
well uh definitely when we try to assess
uh the putin strategy and uh mindset uh
it's not about rational thinking so if
you
uh we
expected that
my our western partners that uh you
shouldn't count on uh economic costs uh
imposed in russia that this would induce
them to change the behavior but what we
expect uh as an effect of these economic
sanctions so far the russian uh
population uh ordinary russians have
been silenced on on on what's going on
on ukraine they didn't show the
discontent with the policy of the
political leadership
because they were suppressed by the
regime but once they experience this
discomfort extreme discomfort when they
can't pay with cars when they can't use
these cars in europe when
they see huge inflation and all this
stuff this would um
actually induce the
level of
outrage of russian population at some
point at some point this inflection
point hasn't come yet
but i think it's a matter of a couple of
days or nearest weeks and also what
we're doing we're trying to show the
real information to the russian society
for instance we've got access to the
whole databases personal details of all
the
uh 120
uh thousands of troops who are actually
engaged in this major companion ukraine
and this applied these two to the
russian side for for ordinary russians
just be able to look into it and to see
their sons fathers or relatives there
yeah it's an alternative narrative from
what they might be getting officially
julia thank you so much for joining us
today yulia osmolovska joining us from
kiev please stay safe we appreciate your
being here this is bloomberg quick take